[Music]
Vladimir Putin said moments ago that
Russia will increase its air strikes on
Ukraine in the coming days weeks and
[Music]
months hey I need to show you this
missile really quick cuz it teaches us a
lot this is a Russian missile it's got
Wings on it it can travel a very far
distance and Russia has been using these
types of missiles in their war in
Ukraine since the very beginning of the
war they fire them at Railway stations
and electric grids and whenever
something like this happens
investigators rush to the scene not only
to recover the casualties to rush people
to the hospital but also to sift through
this
debris all this mangled metal and
material this missile debris contains
important Clues if you zoom in you're
going to see something crazy this little
component inside of this missile has the
logo of a company called vior which is
an American company over the the course
of this war investigators have been
looking into this debris to try to
understand how Russia is making their
missiles what ingredients they're using
and where those ingredients come from so
without Western technology Russia
wouldn't be able to build
missiles and it's not just one power
converter from vior this missile is
packed with microelectronics the key
most sophisticated parts of the missile
that come from the West like the
communication controller which is made
by zylog another American company the
guidance system which runs on three
microprocessors all three made by the
American company Texas Instruments and
then of course the brains of the whole
thing the microchips they're made by
Intel the American chip giant that is
currently being subsidized by the US
government to make more chips future of
the chip industry is going to be made in
America made in America all in all
investigators from the Ukrainian
government from the Royal United
Services Institute or rusi and others
found that Russia needs 450 Western made
components for their weapons the
majority of which come from the United
[Music]
States this is stuff they can't make on
their own they need it from the outside
we know that the Russian systems from
their most basic systems to their most
sophisticated systems are critically
dependent on Western
microelectronics Ukraine is making an
effort to gather Western Air defense
which then shoot down missiles that are
made possible by the west by Western
microchips that's Alexis Sorokin the
deputy chief editor of the keev
independent which is the largest English
language newspaper in Ukraine they've
been covering the war we've been working
with them to investigate how technology
is affecting this war for this story we
looked into how this Western Tech is
making it into Russian killing
machines the keev independent received
this leaked report from the Ukrainian
government that that gives us more clues
as to how this technology is making it
into Russia illegally flowing through a
shadowy network of shell companies fake
aliases circuitous shipping routes all
to evade sanctions and arrive to front
companies for the Russian
military many of them eventually ending
up in missiles or drones or other vital
weapons being used to invade Ukraine and
kill its
people this is a quintessential case of
Modern Warfare how microt technology
used for computers is being weaponized
and flowing through the complicated
global economy I want to show you how
this is happening and what can be done
about
it I need to quickly tell you about
another shadowy Market thank you incog
for sponsoring today's video so what
happens in the shadowy data broker
Market is that you have a profile all of
the stuff that helps companies and
people search sites Target you and call
you and email you and send stuff to your
house I find this fairly violating so
the way this works is you sign up for
incognate and you give them permission
to act on your behalf to go out and to
make a request to these hundreds of data
broker lists that you and I are on to
tell them that you want to be off the
list and by law these companies are
required to take you off the list that's
what's awesome once you give them
permission you get access to this
dashboard you get to see all of the
requests they've sent out since I signed
up for incognate my phone has been
quieter my email's been more chill my
house has not been inundated with as
much junk mail and I feel a lot better
knowing that my information is not on
like people search sites or that
insurance companies aren't using my
browser history to like jack up my
premiums there's a link in my
description it's incog Johny Harris you
can sign up for the annual plan and get
60% off you do the annual plan so that
incognet can be like constantly
scrubbing you off of these lists because
you're always being added to new lists
when you click the link it helps support
the channel too so please use the link
but you also get that discount thank you
incog for sponsoring today's video for
supporting our journalism and now we are
going to unpack this thing that has been
like deep on our minds for several
months now which is the shadowy
smuggling Market that is getting
American and Western Tech into Russia
get
ready since the beginning of the
full-scale invasion of Ukraine in
February of 2022 Vladimir Putin's Army
has launched over 5,000 cruise missiles
into
Ukraine what happened is Russia Russia
wasn't able to conquer Ukraine in the
first month or two in October 2022
Russia came up with this new tactic it
will use missiles to destroy Ukraine's
energy infrastructure and kill Ukraine's
economy and force people to negotiate
these missiles have killed thousands of
civilians they've leveled homes and
communities and they've destroyed the
economy and daily life of many
ukrainians so in response to this
Invasion the West responded not only by
giving weapons and money to Ukraine to
fight this war but also trying to cut
Russia off from the global economy
including being cut off from these vital
microelectronics that they need to build
their missiles to build their weapon
systems this is what sanctions do it
makes it illegal for a company like
Texas instrument or Intel to sell their
microchips to Russia again Russia can't
make this stuff on their own so the idea
was that if you could cut Putin off of
the chips then he would eventually run
out of the ingredients he needed to
continue to make missiles and other
weapon systems that he was using in
Ukraine
at least that's what they thought would
happen Russia has been able to produce
more missiles in 2023 than was able to
produce in
2022 Russia didn't run out the missiles
kept flying and the drones kept coming
well tonight a third of Ukraine is
without power after Russia destroyed
power stations in the last 8 days and to
find out how this is happening Ukrainian
investigators have been Gathering
remnants of Russian weapons bringing
them to these missile
graveyards like this one that the KE
independent team helped us get access
to at these missile graveyards
investigators dissect the wreckage and
look inside to understand how these
Russian weapons work to try to gain an
advantage in this war but what they
found was
[Music]
surprising they were finding that these
components were coming from American
companies like Texas Instruments and
Analog Devices investigators have looked
into dozens of missiles and they keep
finding the same thing us and Western
technology that is somehow making it
into Russian missiles and drones long
after economic sanctions should have cut
off the flow these are the chips they
need for their guidance systems their
wireless communication for their
targeting critical components that
Russia can't make on their own how
exactly is the Russian military getting
their hands on Western microelectronics
even after sanctions went into place
that made it illegal for Western
companies to send micro Electronics to
Russia and the answer is this
[Music]
map this map shows at least a part of a
shadowy network a market that Russia
uses to keep vital technology secretly
flowing into Russian
weapons this Tech travels through the
veins of the global economy using
loopholes shell companies and convoluted
shipping routes to escape these
[Music]
sanctions now let's be clear this is not
the whole network this is a shadowy
black market it's very hard to see and
to report on but thanks to some amazing
reporting by Reuters by rusy by the KE
independent the financial times and
others we've been able to piece together
what this looks like how Russia gets its
hands on these
microchips let's start here in New York
City where we know that two companies
were registered in Brooklyn as
electronic components Distributors both
of them were owned by the same three
guys who used aliases like Nick stevens
or Geo Ross These companies have been
shipping millions of dollars worth of
electronics from various locations in
New York to several middleman countries
countries that have no rules about
sending stuff to Russia from there this
technology was then shipped into Russia
to a company that makes weapons for the
Russian military when these guys got
busted investigators found that the
specific microchips that they were
shipping into Russia were the specific
chips that Russia uses for various
weapon platforms that they're using in
their war in
Ukraine in another case this one company
based in Singapore starts buying
American microchips from the US and
selling
$250,000 worth of chips to a company
inside of Russia who seemingly has
nothing to do with the Russian
government that company then sold them
to another Russian company called Robin
trade but it turns out that Robin trade
is just one of many fake companies that
sells to yet another fake company called
Sera engineering that we now know is
actually just a front for the Russian
spy agency the
FSB this convoluted daisy chain of like
fake companies is used to hide the fact
that the FSB the Russian intelligence
agency is procuring chips through this
Network to make it look like this was
some civilian tech company importing
these chips one of the greatest Tools in
this network is the shell company the
fact that in our global economy you can
make a company by signing a few papers
and paying a fee and then you can start
doing business under the name of that
company like there was this one computer
parts company in Germany that before the
war was selling technology to Russia but
after Putin's Invasion EU sanctions
banned that company from doing this so
the German company starts selling chips
to this shell company in Turkey which
immediately turns around and sells them
right to Russia custom records show that
in just 7 months this new Turkish
company sent $20 million worth of
computer parts to Russia including
us-made microchips and the missiles just
kept on flying Ukraine says Russia has
fired at least 80 missiles at Targets
across the country as part of an
overnight bombardment so you can see
that it's like a lot of these middlemen
countries that the chips are being sort
of trafficked through to evade sanctions
and this has given a lot of attention to
to a bunch of random countries that were
never a part of this technology trade
before like the Maldives this island
nation that is much more known for like
instagrammable vacation photos they had
no real semiconductor microchip industry
before this and yet right after Putin's
Invasion the malds started seeing ships
arrive with hundreds of thousands of
microchips arriving at their ports only
to immediately turn around and head for
Russia but when they pull into the port
they do have to register with the custom
agents and so we have Customs records
which shows us where this stuff is
coming from these records show us that a
lot of these chips are coming from a
company registered in Hong Kong but who
was owned by a company in Singapore
which is in turned owned by a company
registered in the sell Islands oh and
this company which a Reuters journalist
found was just an empty office in Hong
Kong full of boxes has only one officer
a Spanish citizen who owns an airplane
Club in Catalonia and yet somehow this
company is responsible for over $200
million of electronics being sent to
Russia including $50,000 of Intel and
AMD microchips and as we saw much of it
flowing through the
Maldives I mean do you see how this
works like yes it is legal for someone
to send microchips from the United
States of America to Russia but when you
have shell companies in middlemen
countries that are not a part of the
sanctions you can kind of get around
that pretty easily there's this one
company in China called King Pai
technology they do the same thing they
buy Western shs from companies in like
India and then they sell them to Russian
companies that are known to do business
with the Russian military the United
States government found out about this
and cracked it down they put kingp
technology on the list the sanctions
list that says that American companies
are not allowed to send them microchips
but lucky for them they've got a bunch
of other companies that do the exact
same thing that aren't on the list they
have a whole network of these shell
companies owned by these two guys that
confusingly have the same last name so
these guys just keep sending Western
microchips ships to the Russian military
now just under another
name the US caught on again and they
cracked down on that company but this
will not stop them because they'll just
operate out of another one of their
shell companies one day your kingp Pai
technology the next day you're 3hc
semiconductor this is the game of
whack-a-mole that enforcers are stuck in
Shell companies are disposable they're
pieces of paper so it's really hard
really slow really complicated and
difficult to enforce and in many cases
the middleman countries like the
Maldives have no real incentive to crack
down on this all it means for them is
just more traffic through their ports
like you've got Russia's neighbor
Kazakhstan where Imports of microchips
mysteriously doubled after Russia's
fullscale Invasion because now you've
got Smugglers using it as a middleman
like this Dutch guy who started shipping
microchips to Russia via Kazakhstan to
disguise the real destination some of
this stuff is so obvious like Kyan a
country that almost no one on earth has
ever heard about but who saw a huge
increase in the their imports from
Germany after all these sanctions went
into place almost a 1,000% increase
which like they're not complaining this
just means more activity of imports from
other countries even though we all kind
of know that they're just a middleman
for smuggling stuff into Russia
now so that's the answer that's how
Russia is getting Western made
microchips into their country despite
all of these sanctions that should make
it illegal this is how their fuel their
war machine that leaked report that we
saw from the Ukrainian government was a
plea for help it was a sounding of the
alarm Bells it was given to Western
diplomats at a summit to basically say
hey guys thanks for all the money that
you're giving to us the weapons the
anti-missile and anti-air defenses but
you're also giving technology to our
enemy those drones and missiles that
we're shooting down with your defenses
they also have your technology in them
but if we stop this chain Ukraine needs
less from the United States so basically
what happens now is that the United
States is providing weapons that defend
Ukraine from weapons produced with the
help of companies from the United States
there isn't any immediate solution but
what we can do is we can just gum up
their supply chains we can arrest their
Intelligence Officers we can introduce
crap into their supply chain we can just
make it longer more difficult more
expensive this story is useful for us to
understand because it's one of the best
examples of how war is changing how
large scale War Works in our modern
world how these little silicon chips are
vital for any modern Army and that those
who produce them think that they're The
Gatekeepers that they can stop the world
from getting their hands on this Tech
and what we're seeing is they really
can't at least not fully no matter what
the US and its allies do to try to
control who gets microchips and who
doesn't the complexity of the global
economy makes it nearly impossible to do
so and yet that doesn't mean they
shouldn't keep trying but here we're
talking about protecting the lives of
civilians right it's a solvable issue
it's a complicated issue but it's a
solvable issue and that's what gets me
is that if I knew personally that some
kind of action from myself can help save
an innocent person I definitely do it
and I hope that people in the states or
people in in Europe would also feel this
way about protecting Ukraine
thank you for watching this video I know
the world is having a bit of a lapse in
interest and attention towards WS the
very real existential war in Ukraine and
I still think it's very important and we
have to keep an eye on it because the
security of Ukraine is actually the
security of the West and we have to keep
paying attention to it so that's why we
made this story I want to just briefly
thank the sponsor one more time like we
can't make these videos these Deep dive
videos that require a lot of resources
without sponsors incog is this service
that goes out and Advocates on your
behalf for the data that the world has
about you your data is B and sold in an
open market you have a profile that is
on a bunch of different lists and incog
goes out and requests that that data be
taken off those lists so that you can
not be on a bunch of people's search
sites or be marketed to in ways that you
don't want to so I'm grateful that incog
exists there's a link in my description
that you should use if you do want to
sign up for the annual plan you get 60%
off thanks in cogy again for sponsoring
today I am also grateful for those who
support us at The Newsroom The Newsroom
is a community on patreon where we
publish a vlog every month it's sort of
a behind the scenes on how how things
get done here in the studio we have a
poster about maps that may or may not
still exist because it we we did our
last batch of printing and it may be
sold out by the time you're watching
this I do not know but it the link will
be in the description if it still exists
we sell LS and presets which is how we
color our photos and videos and we have
a new channel called search party where
we unpack the most important topics in
geopolitics and Global sports with my
old Vox colleague Sam Ellis it is search
Party on YouTube and you should go watch
it cuz it's pretty good stuff I think
that's all I have to say here at the
very end of the video thank you all for
being here and I will see you in the
next
one
[Music]
dunzo